O.
MY S
T .
>> Translator: EXPLAWHERE EYNGLD
D TO MOBSPI URTIZENSL OURADIA TI
HT NOW.FRLIC.
OUN I SAY  HAV ARMY OF
POWERFIC
ARE OW A
THEND ESE Y FIGHTINGF S INONTHEE
AVEY CAME TOD.UKRAINIS ATTACKE
AIE RTTHE MAINSTATEHOOD, BUT III
ONE
WENGSI
.EAPS TO ALLTHOSBLE OF SOVERGNYT
PLEASE FORMATEDOMYO
CONDITIO EPANESS PN ONTURESAKEF
Y AND FOR YO, F NEED TBE
D
SE
THE TID THNKKRAINETHE
URS
E RESOURCE,
EVERYTHING TO PROVIDE FOND
INRE PEOE.UR
O ANFENSE OF OURDEE. HL PONENTS.
OFY AN A OF OUDOM.O PP STATE EST
THIDED
TOEMOVE HAS BEEN AE UPMSF TERRI.
NI MNIONT IT IS A DIFFEN
HISTOR AND RUSSIA.
WE HAVS F T DE T
UKRAINIANS, T E ON OURANE HIGHEE
TWA IN
WAR.FROM ARE SD HISTORY.L
IN RUSSIASOO SSIANS.THE
I KNOW THATH I
R CITIZENS O CITS MILIESOUCKTORY
SS ABOUT
TRUTH.HE W
IMPORTANU.UPDATE YOU EVEL  TO YR
LT
GLORY TOO.THINIAT MYR ZELENSWI.S
AREN'T SEEINATATCHING HES TI OUT
US HERE ARSEIN
UTIVES AND FRIENDS INA
O RECTLYND PROTEST
HETHENHASTAINECASUALTIES, HER DO
NOWO OUWALSH INHE OF ESERAR STW
STRIKIBAY LLG ONT OUETED A
GO FIG
>> Rep TOWH
TO SOM A CAL
A SIGNF
E
EATHIS